it's getting hot the reaction started we
now have a column of carbon appearing
out of the top of this this beaker so
Furyk acid is one of the most common
chemicals in the sense that it is made
in the larger scale millions of tonnes a
year okay so what we're going to do now
is we're going to do a few experiments
with with sulfuric acid so the first one
we're going to do is we're going to put
some sulfuric acids all some sulfuric
acid into water which is an exothermic
reaction so we should say get hot
fortunately I haven't had any major
mishaps with sulfuric acid but like many
chemists when they start I made the
mistake of trying to add water to
sulfuric acid if you have concentrated
sulfuric acid and you want to dilute it
for an experiment it's very important
that you don't put the water into the
acid so what we have is the sulfuric
acid hit in here in here we've got some
boy pointy-stick is very good so we've
got some water in here and this is a
thermocouple so it's going to measure
the temperature in the water because
when you mix the acid and the water even
though they don't react you generate a
lot of heat because you're forming
hydrogen bonds between the acid and the
water and the result is if you drop the
water in the acid the water boils
instantly and the acid spits out and if
you're looking closely at the stuff it
spits out on to you now I have had the
not looking in my face
but I have had this spitting in case if
you put a little bit in
over here give it a stir it's got ah
there you go
okay so already we're reading so it was
set about 20 degrees when we first
started if I do it nice and slow ish
hopefully do too much okay our tablet
has now gone up so it's really important
if you're you trying to dilute
concentrated acid that you take the
water and add the acid to the water
gradually making it stronger rather than
taking strong acid and adding the water
to try and make it weak it's quite a bit
I think we get into boiling now so what
we hit 97 degrees C and you can actually
see that it's actually starting to boil
the water I've never actually seen pure
sulfuric acid which is meant to be a
really sort of treacly stuff treacly it
means it's very viscous like syrup of
sugar that you sometimes put on your
waffles or your breads or cakes this
sulfuric acid we use in the lab is
diluted with water either very dilute or
even concentrated sulfuric acid still
has quite a lot of water in it so it
looks pretty runny the shape of the
molecule is quite simple there is a
sulfur atom which has four oxygens
around it and on two of the oxygens you
have a hydrogen atom so the formula is
h2 so4 the formula h2so4 is one that a
lot of people who know nothing about
chemistry have heard this formula don't
know what it means but it sounds
scientific it's actually munching
through the paper in case it's reacting
with the paper with the kitchen paper
you can see it going okay it's pretty
potent stuff it's like burning almost so
we can take this to the next level
something you might have seen before we
can dehydrate sugar sulfuric acid used
to be called in eighteenth century
before that oil of vitriol we still use
the expression English
vitriolic which means really violent
reaction you know when you tell the boss
that you made a real mistake
the response is vitriolic the reason for
this is that sulfuric acid reacts so
easily one of the reactions is that it
can absorb large amounts of water even
though you've got to the formula h2so4
it is a very strong dehydrating agent e
can remove water from other compounds so
what about 300 sugar collector 500
resale furyk we're going to try that one
if you take a whole range of organic
compounds your body sugars most of these
have a formula that is approximately
ch2o and if you add the acid to these
materials or you spill it on yourself
what happens is the h2o is abstracted
and you're left with black carbon so
here we have some sugar common or garden
supermarket sugar and we're going to put
the sugar into this of some sugar into
this beaker add some sulfuric acid and
see what happens
there was a well-known murderer called
Hague in the in London in the early
1950s who murdered his victims he then
drank a cup of their blood and some
people said because the food in the
hotel where he lived was so bad and then
he dissolved their bodies in sulfuric
acid in the bath and he was discovered
because teeth were found in the drain
pipes afterwards I've got sugar in if
you have it now chemists use sulfuric
acid for all sorts of reactions it is
the acid that you use in the batteries
in cars so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to add some
should turn around tonight some
concentrated sulphuric acid okay when we
try and give it a little bit of a stir
hopefully as well to get everything nice
and mixed and all of you have a dash
down we'll see what happens when people
are refining oil to make diesel and
petrol gasoline they remove sulfur from
the oil because otherwise it causes
atmospheric pollution so oil refineries
end up with large amounts of sulfur and
one of the most economic uses for the
sulfur is to turn it into sulfuric acid
so the raw materials are very cheap and
the applications are very wined it's
getting hot okay you see it's getting
hot the reaction started we now have a
column of carbon appearing out of the
top of this this beaker Wow pretty
freaky isn't it okay so you can see the
steam coming off of this okay this
reaction is absolutely boiling hot
okay so here actually I can probably
give every bug it's quite hard actually
and so what we've got basically is a
column of carbon a column of carbon and
because what we've done is tougher gases
is dehydrated all of the all of the
sugar so we've just got carbon left